[Musique]
nouvelle édition du club de la presse
sur tv 78 avec radio marmite 88.4 toutes
les nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr merci de
nous rejoindre pour alexandre marquer et
à nordine agne bonjour à tous les deux
voici le sommaire de cette émission du
mois de juillet une page qui se tourne
attrape un changement de majorité à la
verrière le rassemblement national qui
perd sa seule commune d'ile-de-france à
mantes-la-ville voici quelques-uns des
résultats des élections municipales qui
viennent de se dérouler mais quels sont
les grands enseignements du scrutin pour
les formations politiques nous en
parlerons dans un instant qui sont les
personnalités du mois chaque média
mettra en avant en deuxième partie
d'émission celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité et du département et puis
les sujets qui seront traités bientôt
par vos médias locaux dans les prochains
jours à ce sera notre rubrique bientôt à
la une à l'actualité à du mois ce sont
donc les municipales et leurs
conséquences pour nous accompagner une
invitée aurore bergé
bonjour à vous mon genre députés l om
des yvelines porte parole également du
mouvement les journalistes présents vont
pouvoir vous interrogez vous faire
réagir c'est alexandre marqué des
nouvelles 7,8 actus.fr qui va débuter
pour évoquer la question de rambouillet
notamment alexandre oui bonjour je
voulais savoir comment vous expliquer le
résultat de jean schmitt ça à
rambouillet alors que l om a vidé des
très bons résultats lors d'initiatives
et de la présidentielle et le fait qu'il
soit arrivé
du coup troisième lors du deuxième tour
et liste sur laquelle vous étiez engagé
d'ailleurs je trouve tout à fait écoutez
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de facteurs
déjà on a eu et je pense que ça c'est
une alerte pour nous tous une app store
sous moi qui n'a jamais été aussi forte
surtout sur une élection qui d'habitude
est une élection qui intéressent nos
concitoyens et sur laquelle ils se
mobilisent
on a eu quand même cette abstention
record y compris dans les huit en
général nous avons des taux de
participation dans notre département qui
sont bien supérieurs
à ce qu'on peut avoir au niveau au
niveau national un décalage important
aussi dans le temps pour des raisons
très compréhensible et sanitaire entre
le premier et le second tour qui fait
qu'on a bien vu dans la campagne qui
était très différente de la manière avec
laquelle on peut faire campagne
habituellement on avait aussi du mal
réintéresser à ce scrutin
quelque part le résultat du premier tour
faisait deux fois pour beaucoup
d'électeurs considéré que les choses
avaient été dites à ce moment là et donc
ça va être ça a été très compliqué de
réinstaller aussi de et de maintenir de
l'intérêt ensuite il faut se dire les
choses il faut se dire que la république
en marche
c'est un mouvement qui est né en 2016 et
c'est pas un mouvement issu du rpr de
l'ump puis les républicains est installé
depuis des dizaines d'années dans la vie
politique française national et local
pas plus le parti socialiste et donc on
a quatre ans d'existence et en quatre
ans d'existence
il faut qu'on arrive à développer
progressivement aussi cet ancrage local
son relationnel avec les associations
avec les entreprises avec les citoyens
et ça prend du temps mais je pense qu'il
faut l'accepter il faut accepter qu'un
territoire comme rambouillet qui est
dirigée de fait par gérard larcher
depuis très longtemps
ce qui est encore le cas de fait
aujourd'hui est bien en effet il faut qu
nous on ait la possibilité de faire nos
preuves et qu'on accepte d'abord d'être
des élus dans l'opposition permettant
aussi d'incarner une alternative c'est
compliqué quand vous êtes au pouvoir
vous même d'être en capacité d'incarner
une alternative localement on le sait
bien et ça se vérifie souvent scrutin
local après scrutin local et je crois
que c'est ça la responsabilité qui va
être la nôtre aujourd'hui c'est de
démontrer comment août ferait nous
différemment sur le territoire
j'ai moi en tant que député de toute
façon mon objectif c'est travailler et
je le ferai comme j'ai toujours fait
depuis des 1017 avec l'ensemble des élus
qui ont été choisis par nos concitoyens
sur l'abstention si on peut juste arrêté
sur sur ce sujet là pour vous
l'abstention du second tour est lié
uniquement à la crainte de l'épidémie où
ça c'est plus profond que ça il ya une
vraie crise démocratique qui s'exprime
je pense
deux choses il ya à la fois le sujet
sanitaire qui a continué à inquiéter
quand même certains de nos concitoyens
mais surtout il ya eu ce décalage
à partir du moment où vous avez un
entre-deux tours qui est pas vraiment un
entre-deux tours puisque on a tous mis
entre parenthèses évidemment nos
campagnes pendant la période du
confinement
vous avez quand même trois mois de
décalage donc le second tour encore une
fois beaucoup moins intéressé que toute
la campagne qu'on avait fait avant le
premier tour mais oui il ya un mal être
qui est plus profond qui en vrai sujet
démocratique et je pense que c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut absolument
qu'on accepte de faire différemment
d'innover ce qu'on fait avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat par
exemple ça c'est significatif d'une
nouvelle manière de faire vivre la
démocratie
on n'est pas là pour avoir les citoyens
d'un côté les élus de l'autre il faut
qu'on arrive à faire ensemble
alors après oui quand vous avez des
parlementaires quand vous avez des mères
vous avez une démocratie représentative
et vous faites confiance à vos élus pour
qu'ils prennent les décisions et les
bonnes décisions
pendant la période que vous leur avait
confié le mandat que vous leur avec mon
pied et pour autant peut plus se
contenter d'avoir uniquement l'élection
qui vient sanctionner la relation entre
le citoyen et les lui il faut qu'on
arrive à avoir ce lien démocratique
beaucoup plus approfondie y compris hors
période électorale je crois que ça c'est
une priorité il faut aussi aller au bout
et moi j'y tiens beaucoup de la réforme
institutionnelle
cette réforme elle a été bloquée elle a
été bloquée par l'opposition de droite a
été bloqué au sénat c'est que gérard
larcher n'en veut pas mais je pense
qu'elle est nécessaire dire que il faut
un non cumul des mandats dans le temps
et on l'a bien vu d'ailleurs que ce soit
dans les yvelines au niveau national à
gauche comme à droite des élus qui
étaient là depuis parfois trop longtemps
jugée comme étant l'appui trop longtemps
par les électeurs ont été clairement
sanctionné par une demande de
renouvellement et je pense qu' il vaut
mieux inscrire dans la loi le non cumul
des mandats dans le temps
je pense qu'il faut inscrire dans la loi
qu'il faut de la proportionnelle une
part de proportionnelle aux législatives
pour qu'on ait une assemblée nationale
il soit plus représentative et donc
aussi mieux accepté donc je crois que ça
c'est une attente qui est quand même
hein
portant sûr que ça viendra jamais en
tête des priorités surtout quand on est
en période de crise le dire qu'avant les
questions économiques et sociales et à
la question institutionnelle mais c'est
un enjeu démocratique majeur et le poids
qu'il faut qu'on aille où vous parliez
du non renouvellement de certains
mandats en tout cas de les limiter dans
le temps peut-être avec noureddine on
peut s'arrêter sur le cas la situation
de trappe parce que lrm le parti
présidentiel a fait le choix de soutenir
un candidat qui avait effectué plus d'un
mandat nouradine ont effectivement ça
allait être le quatrième mandat de guy
malandain
sans compter bien sûr tous ses mandats
précédents il a été député il a été a
notamment eu lieu dans d'autres dans
d'autres villes également mais est ce
que c'est la possible nationale alors
elle n'a peut-être pas été assez claire
or berger parce que le candidat qui a
été soutenu guy malandain qui était
plutôt au fait qu'il y avait une liste
plutôt hostile à la république au mans
soit en tout cas à la politique
présidentielle même si la première
adjointe jeanine mari était adhérente
elle-même du de la république en marche
et c'était un angle d'attaqué y aura de
talent irabé principaux concurrents qui
a marché puisque on a remarqué que cette
liste de guy malandain a eu du mal à se
situer par rapport à ce soutien à l om
et qu'il était obligé à chaque fois de
dire non c'est pas vraiment un soutien
c'est plus une adhésion de la députée et
nadia et voilà est-ce que ça va pas
apporter de la confusion à ce débat vous
aviez attrape des candidats issus des
trois principales vingt trois des
principales formations politiques qui se
retrouver au second tour où vous aviez
un candidat des républicains avec
madness roux vous avez un candidat du
parti socialiste qui était ali rabais et
vous avez un candidat soutenu par la
majorité présidentielle et qui était le
maire sortant guy malandain donc je
crois que politiquement les choses
étaient était assez clair après vous
avez toujours un contexte politique où
parfois telle ou telle étiquette plus
être jugé ou considérés comme plus ou
moins favorables plus ou moins simples
ça je ne sais pas j'ai pas fait la
compagnie tra donc je peux pas vous
vous savez mieux que moi probablement ce
qui s'est passé ce que je sais c'est
qu'on avait ces trois candidats en lice
trois candidats qui sont aussi connus
maintenant est implanté sur trappe à
lire à baqem été adjoint de guy
malandain
il a travaillé auprès de benoît hamon il
était le collaborateur donc il était
aussi très visible et en création
territoire hackman lascroux c'est la
deuxième fois qu'il se présentait aux
élections municipales attrapé il est
également élu conseiller régional donc
on avait quand même 3 trois hommes trois
candidats mais qui sont connus sur le
territoire et qui représentait aussi
politiquement des idées qui peuvent
êtres qui peuvent être différentes
vous savez le scrutin il peut paraître
aussi souvent cruel nous aussi
quand on a gagné les élections
législatives en 2017
on a battu des hommes et des femmes qui
avaient été aussi extrêmement investi
engagé engagé à l'assemblée engagés dans
leur territoire et vous avez un moment
une demande très puissant de
renouvellement exactement très puissant
de renouvellement en 2010 est elle
s'exerçait au bénéfice de celles et ceux
qui étaient engagés aux côtés du
président de la république et moi
j'assume d'avoir été lui aussi
évidemment grâce à cette dynamique là et
aux municipales je crois qu'il ya eu
aussi une très forte demande de
renouvellement
elle s'est en fonction des territoires
et aussi en fonction en métropole ou des
territoires plus urbain exercé aux
bénéfices soit d'un bloc de gauche soit
plutôt dlr donc jute et ça peut aussi
paraître cruel parce que froch le bilan
guy malandain il est quand même un bon
bilan pour cette cette ville de trappes
donc c'est ca quelque chose aussi de
douloureux de voir comme ça en maire
sortant être belle il mais je crois
aussi que c'est une nécessité comme je
disais tout à l'heure de renouvellement
démocratique et parfois malheureusement
et là c'est difficile d'accepter de ne
pas se représenter
quand on a un bilan contourna on s'est
engagé toute sa vie quasiment pour pour
une commune et pour un territoire mais
je crois que parfois il faut accepter
aussi de passer la main sinon c'est les
électeurs qui décident pour vous oui
donc sur trois quatre hommes surtout à
83 ans oui mais vous savez
et ça a été le cas dans d'autres
communes y compris dans des plus grandes
communes on a des hommes et des femmes
et quel que soit leur parti politique
qui pour certains d'entre eux se sont
engagés toute leur vie durant et toute
leur vie a été tourné vers ça alors on
peut considérer qu'aujourd'hui ce n est
plus possible
je fais partie de ceux qui vous disent
que c'est plus possible je n'ai pas
vocation à être député pendant trente
ans de ma vie je ne pense pas que ce
soit une bonne chose de vouloir
absolument durée mais je peux comprendre
aussi que quand vous avez été à ce point
engagez vous avez du mal à accepter de
ne pas aller au bout et projets que vous
avez porté il ya aussi un engagement qui
est un engagement sincère il ya de
l'infection ja c'est pas aussi simple la
politique c'est aussi c'est aussi de
l'humain il faut l'accepter donc oui on
peut se dire à froid est-ce qu'à 80 ans
est bien raisonnable de se re présenter
à une élection on peut aussi se dire on
a en face de nous un homme une équipe
qui sont engagés pour une ville qu'ils
ont en grande partie transformé qui ont
fait du bien à ce territoire et qui ont
commencé à en changer aussi je pense
la nature la perception de l'image et
c'est compliqué aussi d'accepter c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense
vraiment qu'il vaut mieux que cette
décision elles viennent d'une réforme
institutionnelle qui parce que vous ne
pouvez plus le faire pour pour avancer
un petit peu sur la discussion et puis
garder du temps pour évoquer les
conséquences un de ces élections
municipales juste en deux mots pour vous
dans le département des yvelines pour la
république en marche
votre regard sur les résultats c'est une
victoire c'est une défaite
je pense que c'est ni l'un ni l'autre je
peux pas vous dire que c'est une
victoire parce que j'aurais aimé qu'on
puisse aller encore plus à la conquête
mais c'est pas une défaite parce que je
vois qu'on a cette mère adhérents de la
république en marche qui ont gagné des
villes et qui sont des villes aussi
significatif dans notre territoire qui
vont du chesnay à verneuil les essarts
le roi joueurs qu'on cherche cran dans
mon territoire donc ça c'est aussi une
part de renouvellement je vois aussi
qu'on a grâce à la république en marche
poursuivi le renouvellement avec des
hommes et des femmes qui pour la
première fois sur devenu adjoint au
maire conseiller
oh on a su mais aussi de faire des
alliances de travailler avec des maires
qui était sur ton alors parfois ça n'a
pas réussi
voilà on a longuement parlé de trappes
mais dans beaucoup d'autres villes
ces alliances elles ont été fructueuses
elles avaient elles ont eu du sens
le soin à sartrouville que soit conflans
sainte honorine que ce soit à poissy que
60 germain en laye nous avons travaillé
et nous travaillons avec les maires en
place et aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de man de la réplique en vain le citoyen
engagé en sont devenus des adjoints des
conseillers municipaux et ça c'était
aussi l'objectif qui était de permettre
ce renouvellement est de travailler en
bonne intelligence avec les maires avec
lesquels c'était possible l'enseignement
au niveau national c'est aussi la percée
écologiste dans le département des
yvelines est un seul maire c'est du côté
d'andrésy qui a réussi à l'emporter un
seul maire écologiste ya néanmoins eu
une percée sur le secteur de rambouillet
aussi sur la ville de rambouillet avec
la candidature de david jutier qui était
arrivé second derrière véronique
matillon qui a donc été élu ça veut dire
quoi pour la suite du mandat le moment
où nous enregistrons cette émission on a
appris la démission d'edouard philippe
donc le gouvernement sera remanié ça ce
n'est pas une grande surprise mais il
faut s'attendre à quoi et vous attendez
vous attendez-vous quoi également en
tant que député la république en marche
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses qu'il
y ait une demande d'un engagement
écologique beaucoup plus assumer plus
pragmatique
oui c'est une certitude et ce n'est
peut-être pas des élections municipales
par contre sens il faut éviter d'avoir
un regard un peu déformé par rapport à
ce second tour des élections municipales
vous prenez à froid les résultats va de
ces élections et que vous regardez le
nombre de maires qui sont aujourd'hui
des mers d'hippologie c'est à dire
qu'ils appartiennent à une formation
politique qui est europe ecologie les
verts
vous avez neuf maires sur les 250 villes
de ne plus de 9000 habitants
donc oui il y à des résultats qui
apparaissent comme étant extrêmement
significatif parce que vous avez un
certain nombre de communes qui était
ancré soit parti socialiste comme
poitiers au strasbourg soit les
républicains comme bordeaux par exemple
qui se transforme et qui au monde au
profit du renouvellement et bien on fait
le choix d'europe écologie les verts
mais je crois qu'il faut éviter de se
dire que c'est ça a été pareil dans tous
les territoires
c'est très peu lucarne ou dans les
yvelines par exemple elle aime la
plupart des maire sortant a été réélu en
vérité et il n'y a pas eu une cette
poussée significative même à rambouillet
en territoire je connais bien je connais
la tante citoyenne sur les enjeux
écologiques que ce soit sur la
transformation et de l'accompagnement de
l'agriculture que ce soit sur les
circuits courts et la relocalisation
que ce soit sur les cantines bio auxois
sur les mobilités les transports la
gratuité des parkings aux abords des
gares évidemment ça c'est de l'écologie
pragmatique nécessaire et on le ressent
bien mais typiquement je pense qu'à
rambouillet ce qui s'est passé c'est que
vous avez un candidat qui était
finalement en effet assez connu et
identifié parce qu'elle se présente
depuis de nombreuses années à
rambouillet et qui était vu comme
l'alternative au delà d'être le candidat
écologiste il était vu comme le candidat
réellement de l'opposition à la majorité
en place
donc je pense qu'il faut pas en tirer de
grands enseignements legreg
renseignements c'est l'enjeu
démocratique lit à l'abstention record
après louis et des résultats qui peuvent
être impressionnants important mais qui
ne sont et qui sont non plus très
différents en fonction des territoires
très urbain en métropole et les
territoires plus ruraux on n'a pas du
tout la même lecture des résultats dans
dans les villes de 10000 15000 et 20000
habitants qui sont la grande majorité de
nos territoires et les grands centres
comme comme les villes que j'évoquais
après évidemment l'engagement écologiste
qui est le no depuis 2010 est il faut
absolument qu'on poursuive la convention
citoyenne pour le climat le fait que le
président de la république se soit
engagé très fortement sur le sujet en
disant que sur 146 des 149 proposition
bien on devait aller au bout soit par
référendum les soumettant directement
aux français soit en les soumettant aux
parlementaires pour les retravailler les
faire aboutir
donc ça c'est un engagement qui est
extrêmement clair quand la convention a
été mise en place
souvenez-vous à des ricanements de tous
ceux qui disaient que ça
marcherait pas que les citoyens n'était
pas habilité à pouvoir faire des
propositions je crois que oui je crois
que ça doit se faire de manière
coordonnée avec le pouvoir politique
encore une fois c'est pas l'un contre
l'autre c'est ensemble il ya des
propositions citoyennes et certaines
seront soumises directement français et
puis d'autres vont revenir en débat au
parlement
noureddine alexandre si vous souhaitez
intervenir sur poser les questions à la
députée sur ce sujet là j'avais une
dernière question concernant ces
municipales est-ce qu'on peut renverser
la questionner la légitimité même de ces
élections quand on voit l'importance de
l'abstention
vous vous souvenez certainement 2017
tous les commentaires
au soir du second tour notamment pour
évidemment de ceux qui n'avaient pas
gagné l'élection
mais qui avait remis en cause la
légitimité légitimité des démêlés macro
disant que c'était une abstention record
au second tour et que voilà ça de monter
en tout cas réflexion est ce que cette
date du 28 juin n'était finalement pas
trop tôt au vu de la crise sanitaire que
l'on connaît que l'on traverse et que
l'on la traversée qui n'est pas finie
bien sûr alors il ya plusieurs questions
sur est-ce que c'était la bonne dette en
vérité c'était la meilleure des dden
dans un contexte qui est un contexte
presque impossible est ce qu'il aurait
fallu décaler encore plus les élections
alors qu'on avait beaucoup de maires
sortants qui soit ne se représentait pas
soit avait été très fragilisés pour
certains au premier tour on se
retrouvait dans une situation
démocratique étaient quand même
compliquées
moi quand j'avais dans mon territoire
des mères qui n'avait pas souhaité se
représenter mais qu'ils restaient en
poste avec leur équipe avait quand même
une difficulté majeure
comment faire pour continuer à faire
tourner comme il se doit nos
municipalités dans ces cas là non je
crois qu'on ne pouvait pas décaler
encore plus au risque sinon encore une
fois d'avoir aussi là un problème
démocratique y compris imaginez quand
vous avez au premier tour un maire qui
était dans une posture très difficile
qui continuait quand même à exercer crs
sa visite est avec une nouvelle équipe
qui aurait aimé s'installer mais qu'il
ne pouvait pas faim on avait des
situations qui était très compliqué d'un
point de vue je trouve démocratique et
de légitimité justement démocratique
et puis avait besoin aussi
progressivement que la vie puisse
reprendre et de préparer la rentrée
scolaire non pas juste là de
déconfinement mais de septembre qui
avait aussi l'urgence d'installer les
nouveaux conseils municipaux après sur
la légitimité moi je trouve ça toujours
très dangereux comme des bas on a des
élections viennent celles et ceux qui
considèrent que ces élections sont
importantes mais quand vous êtes élu
vous êtes élu est légitimement élu que
vous le soyez avec une forte ou une
faible abstention que vous le soyez avec
une forte ou une courte avance parce que
si vous commencez à délégitimer tel ou
tel parlementaire telle mère parce qu'il
aurait été élu avec une abstention
record
ou parce qu'il aurait été lui de
quelques voix alors je crois que là
c'est un vrai problème démocratique que
vous posez si certains veulent poser des
recours administratifs
parce qu'il considère qu'il ya les
difficultés sur cette élection ils le
feront et beaucoup de recours ont
d'ailleurs été vraisemblablement posée
et on verra dans les yvelines s'il y en
a des conséquences mais à partir du
monde vous êtes élu vous êtes élus et
donc vous est légitime a exercé les
responsabilités pour lesquelles vous
avez été choisi je sais que la députée
des obligations derrière donc on va vous
libérer après où est ce que est ce que
vous avez reçu un petit coup de
téléphone c'est la question que j'allais
certain emmanuel macron voilà est-ce que
votre téléphone a sonné en cette période
de remaniement
écoutez je suis en train d'être avec
vous donc de fait je ne peux pas
consulté bien répondu b vont nous le
dire est alors on la prendra peut-être
par là par la presse dans les prochains
jours voilà merci or berger d'avoir été
avec nous c'est le début le club de la
presse du mois de juillet merci à vous
merci
le club de la presse qui se poursuit
avec notre rubrique personnalité du mois
n'aura dit nous débutons avec vous qui
avez vous souhaité mettre à l'honneur ce
mois ci c'était un artiste de trappes
qui s'appelle masse hamels malik donc
qui a une histoire touchante puisque ce
rapport à une maladie un dg dont j'ai
oublié non évidemment ça vous ferait en
tout cas mairie et qui progressivement
le rend aveugle voilà il arrive encore à
distinguer quelques petites formes mais
voilà c'est une maladie qui est qui qui
est vraiment dégénérative et il a sorti
ce mois-ci d'il ya quelques jours un
dernier enfin un titre qui s'appelle
aveugle et voilà puis je voulais lui
rendre hommage tout ce que c'était une
belle chanson voilà c'est le combat d'un
père également qui ne peut plus voir ses
enfants mais qui voilà qui essaye de
rester fort quand même dans les moments
dans ces moments difficiles avec un beau
message et puis c'est une chanson que
j'ai trouvé sympathique aussi
voilà pour allaiter donc voilà c'est ma
personnalité de là et puis les voiliers
n'y voyait pas de de wuala de de
fourberie de ma part en disant qu'en
sortant de ces municipales qui a eu
beaucoup d' aveuglement
voilà ça aurait pu être la chanson
depuis une dissipation peut-être on va
en écouter un extrait en tout cas
extrait près en région va d'écouter un
extrait avant de poursuivre
[Musique]
car j'ai pas compris pourquoi j'ai mal
j'ai mal à la tête
moi j'ai pas la foi
j'ai pas mes enfants je sais pas qui ils
sont mais balla
tous est assombri le voit même plus dans
la lune
ses lacets
faut pas nous inquiéter des sous
sous la pluie
le rappeur trappistes malik masse cms et
votre votre personnalité du moineau adin
alexandra à présent pour toutes les
nouvelles et 7,8 actus.fr votre
personnalité ou vos personnalité normale
mais personnalité en fait c'est un
groupe d'amis talent de locataires de
saint quentin en yvelines qui face aux
problèmes constatés dans leurs
différents quartiers ont décidé d'allier
leurs forces
donc on retrouve la dl théâtre à pour
trouver l'utilité à jean macé
on t'offre meudal logement à malibu à
plaisir on retrouve l'amicale du bois de
l'étang à la verrière et toutes ces
amicales de locataires en constater des
manquements depuis des années donc
insalubrité nettoyage des eaux le
problème de charge problèmes de
chauffage et ils ont décidé de
s'habiller donc unir leurs forces aux
fins d'une forte de fédérations de
locataires et du coup il prévoit de
mener des actions communes dans les mois
à venir avec des manifestations des
actions coup de poing probablement et du
coup c'est un sujet d'actualité puisque
dans le même temps à l'agglomération il
ya une l'agglomération a voté une motion
en rostand le fond contre le bailleur
social valophis attrape visant à
suspendre toute nouvelle garantie
d'emprunt ce d'ailleurs en raison de ses
manquements
du coup on voit que c'est un vrai sujet
d'actualité en ce moment avec eux cette
notamment au coeur de la campagne à
trappes
on en reparlera peut-être plus tard où
tous les candidats ont parlé de ce sujet
là oui c'est un des enjeux nouradine je
me tourne vers vous parce que marmite et
est installée à trappes et vous avez
suivi particulièrement cette campagne
dans la ville
il ya un enjeu fort et important pour le
nouveau maire sa nouvelle équipe a les
rabais va falloir répondre à cette
attente et que ça change et ça va être
compliqué puisque vous venez de citer à
l'instant alexandre vient de citer la
des haltes et alors j'ai reçu le nouveau
maire de trappes mercredi et évidemment
il a chargé la tnt puisque la tnt a
soutenu le candidat n'a through pour
pour le second tour des élections
municipales donc vous voyez l'ambiance
qui a attrapé qui va être compliqué pour
appeler les années à venir
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
une problématique qui est récurrente à
trappes avec la dictée qui fait un
excellent travail qu'il faut souligner
qui essaye de prévenir à l'aller
la puissance publique est sale et de
mettre en avant notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux en sensibilisant le
maximum de personnes faisant des deux
opérations coup de poing pour essayer de
régler tous ces problèmes
ça marche bien en ce qu'il faut ils sont
bien implantés à trappes et du cou à
cette idée de collectif je pense que
c'est une bonne idée qui pourrait voilà
aider les locataires surtout dont
certains beaucoup de difficultés et une
focalisation de ces problématiques sur
trappe il ya peut-être d'autres communes
du département aussi qui sont concernés
on en parle peut être moins et ça a été
moins présent pendant la campagne
exxon oui justement parlé voilà cette
semaine j'ai fait un sujet sur des
locataires à montigné aussi qui viennent
de lancer une pétition contre la
célébrité dans leur quartier la contre
le bailleur cdc l'habitat on voit que
c'est quelque chose qui va plus
largement et pas seulement dans les
quartiers défavorisés et les quartiers
politique de la ville parce que là c'est
à montigny près de près du centre
skywest voyez c est donc on a beau les
temps m'a parlé tout à l'heure le vanni
boua plaisir c'est vraiment un sujet qui
touche tout le monde et toutes les
communes qui sont concernés on le voit
les réactions qui sont diverses les
politiques qui essayent de s'en emparer
et qui sont quelquefois un petit peu
pieds-poings louise liés pour pour agir
en tout cas les locataires de se bouger
dans les prochaines semaines prochains
mois on sait ça devrait sur le secteur
du des yvelines être un sujet vraiment
d'actualité sujet forte personnalité
pour pour télé 78 on va mettre deux
personnalités en avant ils sont 2 c'est
adrian pélissier julien bru ch'ti ce
sont des fondateurs du domaine viticole
la bouche du roi voilà pas de malice non
plus je n'incite pas à la consommation
d'alcool mais en tout cas c'est pour
souligner cette initiative c'est du côté
de d'avron le nom officiel a été
dévoilée voici quelques jours donc
l'appeler la bouche du roi les pieds de
vignes ont été plantées il ya quelques
temps les 30000 première bouteille
devrait bien trop sortir la plantation
date précisément de 2017 c'est le seul
domaine viticole professionnels d'île de
france et il a vu le jour grâce à l'aide
du conseil départemental qui a fait
l'acquisition des terres ayant même pour
l'été un parcours oenotouristique qui
est proposé depuis le 26 juin parcours
avec visite du village découverte des
terres du vignoble est également
dégustation au sein du bosquet est ce
que ça vous tente
moi je bois pas d'alcool donc pas que ça
serait bienvenue or la visite pourquoi
pas oui j'ai eu l'occasion de parler
avec des vignerons c'est très
intéressant
moi j'en vois que modération non c'est
pas ma question savoir si vous étiez
intéressé pour aller découvrir le site
c'était déjà ça et site qui est située à
ada vont donc je vous le disais un seul
domaine viticole professionnels d'île de
france
bravo pour cette installation et ce pari
4 je vais donner quand même pour les
téléspectateurs auditeurs qui nous
suivre pour les amateurs il ya quatre
cépages français qui ont été choisis
pinot noir merlot pour les rouges
chardonnay échelonnant pour les blancs
voilà comme ça c'est conséquence tout
seul il semble pas spécialiste mais
amateur en tout cas aller le club de la
presse qui va se refermer le temps
d'évoquer les sujets à la une demain
alexandre marqué bientôt à découvrir
dans les colonnes de toutes les
nouvelles et sur 7,8 actus.fr on
on part pour montigny le bretonneux avec
la fondation anne de gaulle oui donc la
fondation anne de gaulle c'est une
fondation spécialisée dans le handicap
mental qui a été créé par le général de
gaulle au sortir de la seconde guerre
mondiale en 1945 et moi je lui a donné
le nom de sa fille kaki morte qui était
décédée était trisomique qui est morte à
l'âge de 20 ans et a été déjà très bien
implanté dans les yvelines à versailles
et à un million 1 chapelle et
aujourd'hui elle va créer un nouvel un
nouvel établissement à nouveau foyer à
montigny-le-bretonneux fin 2022
donc ça va être un établissement il y
aura 100 places d'hébergement et il y
aura surtout aussi la voix son
originalité c'est qu'il y aura une sorte
de laboratoire de recherche ou ou des
chercheurs de la faculté de médecine de
saint quentin en yvelines des start up
des ingénieurs vont travailler avec des
handicapés mentaux et leurs familles
autour de différentes thématiques
différents champs d'exploration comme
les troubles liés au stress
l'interaction sociale et ça c'est un
projet complètement inédit en france et
c'est une première
quelques des chercheurs travaille avec
des handicapés mentaux sur le sujet et
ce sera en 2022 pour le terrain est
situé dans l'avenue du parc à montils
libre tu ne sais au village c'est sur
une ancienne emprise de l'autoroute a12
qui étaient là j'ai donc eu jusque là
réservé par l'état et qui finalement du
cousin n'a pas servi et va être cédée
donc à l'agglomération puisse aider à la
fondation
j'en profite pour vous montrer les unes
des nouvelles du 1er juillet donc
actuellement en kiosque pour l'édition
de versa et la piscine de mont boron qui
s'affiche ouverture actées après la
crise sanitaire on autre cycle votre
hebdomadaire revient sur l incendie qui
a réduit en cendres une institution à
plaisir le restaurant gastronomique la
maison des bois situé juste à côté du
golfe pour ceux qui qui s'y repère un
petit peu les dirigeants qui donc après
la crise du covin non subissent cette
nouvelle crise la coup dur
supplémentaire pour eux et puis à la une
pour l'édition de rambouillet à la maire
de rambouillet véronique matillon avec
aussi les visages des nouveaux élus du
sud des yvelines
du côté de tv 78 cordes et en dehors
pardon des grands sujets d'actualité
sachez que dès le 20
juillet vous pourrez aussi découvrir
quotidiennement nos programmes de l'été
idées de sorties de découverte de
pratiques sportif chaque jour nos
journalistes vous emmèneront à elancourt
pour les activités de la commanderie
entre ciné plein air et animations pour
les plus jeunes ou encore à andrésy pour
découvrir l'édition 2022 sculptures en
l'île ou encore à trappes également à
lille de loisirs à noter également le 9
juillet sur notre antenne magazine
complète spécial 7,8 loisirs de l'été
qui sera aussi en replay sur notre site
internet
et j'en viens à un marmite 88,4 ne radie
nouveau aussi focus dans les prochains
jours sur l'actualité de l'été et
notamment on y revient encore à trappes
oui effectivement puisque vous savez à
wilfrid habituellement pendant l'été
attrape ses des trappes plage et loria
pas 450 en continu et avec le co vide la
crise du coran là bas c'est rappela jeu
n'aura pas lieu du coup il ya tout ça il
ya toute une organisation qui s'est mise
en place avec les villages d'été et dans
ce village d'été alors il ya plusieurs
dispositifs les plus achetés à la cité
éducative
il ya plein de choses qui ont été mises
en place pour essayer de permettre
notamment aux enfants de trappes qui
vont pas partir en vacances d'être
occupé pendant cet été du qu'on va
essayer de mettre en avant toutes les
toutes les initiatives qui vont être
mises en place cette semaine
et puis si je peux me permettre les
frites en quelques secondes on recevra
aussi l'équipe de jolis prod ils sont
ils sont du coin ils ont tourné un petit
court métrage d'une vingtaine de minutes
qui s'appelle confinement intime super
sympa sur le confinement très original
donc voilà je vous invite également à
les voir jeudi prod vous tapez jolie
prod et puis vous tomberez sur un
confinement intime c'est très sympa très
original et ça parle du confinement
alexandre votre programme aussi sur
l'été en termes de couverture éditoriale
j'entends et non pas vos vacances
bah oui oui beaucoup les activités d'été
avec notamment une problématique
il va peut-être plus d'animations
s'était notamment à trappes
beaucoup de familles ne partiront pas en
vacances cette année
notamment des nouveaux maire de trappes
a annoncé leurs victoires
la création de stages intensifs pour les
élèves en vue de suivre les
recommandations du président macron de
la lrm avec ses vacances à prenantes
c'était le mot d'ordre finalement
réussit toujours à trouver un terrain
d'entente quelle que soit la formation
voilà en tout cas pour conclure ce club
de la presse dernier avant les vacances
merci aux médias qui ont participé cette
saison marmite avec nordine à nier les
nouvelles cette ut actus.fr alexandre
marqué merci aussi à la gazette à l fm
notre confrère aussi qui est intervenu
ponctuellement bernard delattre ancien
journaliste des yvelines aujourd'hui
écrivain merci à vous bel été à toutes
et à tous on retrouve on se retrouve en
septembre pour le club de la presse sur
tv 78 on se quitte en musique avec un
extrait donc de votre coup de coeur
personnalité votre son de l'été n'aura
dynmaique masse
voilà pour
pour mme adou tête et les couleurs sont
belles et au la mer
où la moyenne
pour matt ou tél
les couleurs de
e
m
ap
[Musique]
j'ai la paix nous plaît
vous avez lé là ne faut pas faible et on
n'a pas le corps de ce pilote
quand je fais les deux vont pas tout est
vert que des histoires
normal quand je m'enferme quand j'ai
tout seul mais faisant comme divers
comme qui veut noyer le rouge comme la
veille à la boue gêne je me disais ah tu
de rebelles j'enverrai avec 12 en or et
vert
[Musique]